if you imagine being somebody website I
can't well peasant so since here are
BuzzFeed we are out of ideas today we're
trying expensive air I honestly think
it's the craziest thing I've ever heard
in my life if this air is really
expensive I do expect it to give me all
the oxygen intake that I need for the
month and also maybe if it gets me a
little high that'd be cool
I'm very picky about what I breathe so
maybe I'll pay for it depends on how
good it is
easy you got that kind of money we work
in the same department instructions open
cap and enjoy all right guys you're
gonna smith some air I don't taste
anything I don't feel anything
his flip-flopping air its air this is
air this is normal air it tastes like
the same air that we are breathing right
now I think these facts are about to be
like we're all dying
the precedent according to the World
Health Organization air pollution poses
the greatest environmental risk to human
health in 2016
the majority of outdoor air pollution
related deaths occurred in Asia Wow
I used to live in Korea and I remember
during soccer games we had to test the
yellow dust that was outside because if
it was too much we couldn't play
air pollution is considered the
fourth-largest threat to human health
following blood pressure dietary risk
and smoking wow I think it's even worse
because smoking is by choice you can
choose not to but air just like what do
you do stay home yeah and even then the
air comes in from outside some
scientists even believe that air
pollution causes birth defects and so in
2016 2.6 million deaths were linked to
air pollution in the house and boy point
three million deaths were linked to
outdoor air pollution that's six million
people in one year I feel like there's
no fixing we don't just don't have kids
everyone I grew up in China until I was
23 by the time when I was 18 like the
air in Beijing just like you can't
really see each other like walk towards
people and I feeling fine so far but who
knows if there's something it's done to
me you know I understand why there is
canned air looking at these facts
pollution is a big problem that we have
it sounds silly to pay for air but if
you're in an environment where you
literally can't breathe or there's
something wrong with your air or air
pollution this is a temporary fix to
your problem moral of the story treat
our planet better so we don't need
canned air this is a great product for
people that really need it it should
really open up conversations about air
pollution and what we can do to make and
create a better environment for all
people live because 7 million people
dying a year
it's not good so let's figure it out
together
[Music]